[Music]
we are heading back to school this month
amid a growing crisis to hire and keep
qualified teachers at the start of last
school year more than 100,000 classrooms
were staffed by teachers not fully
qualified to teach now that's equivalent
to about one classroom for every public
school in the United States nationally
about 20 to 30 percent of new teachers
leave their profession within the first
five years david Begg no is in Bartow
Florida where the County School District
is struggling with shortages David good
morning oh to be back in first grade
good morning we are at floral avenue
elementary orientation starts in about
20 minutes in fact little Dominique is
gonna be sitting right where I am that's
the teacher Miss Lee getting ready she's
been at the district for 23 years you
know they'd love to keep 23 year
teachers like her here as long as she's
been but right now they're struggling to
fill 100 vacancies that's how many
people they need to teach classes and it
doesn't look like they'll meet that
deadline by next week so they're going
to Plan B it's not just in Florida the
shortage is nationwide as superintendent
of schools in Polk County Florida
Jacqueline Byrd needs every qualified
teacher she can get to manage the 104
thousand students she has in her
district but they are going to be short
this year about a hundred teachers when
school starts next week you look at our
generations now younger generations
they're choosing other areas to go into
besides education around the country
between 2009 and 2014 teacher education
enrollments dropped 35% you've been
watching it but we can no longer sit on
the sidelines and just watch it we got
to begin trying to do something so
Bert's taking a new and unconventional
approach just two years ago she began
working with pulk State College and
President Angela Falconeri to create a
teaching Academy the program allows
sophomores in high school to take
teacher education classes that counts
toward their high school and college
degree so by the time they graduate high
school they'll have an associate's
degree and two years later a full
teaching degree it's a quality quality
education that we offer and we prepare
them together as they will have many
internship
and field experience in the public
school system direct employment with the
public school systems we are scrambling
to try to find teachers Maryanne Capozzi
ello is president of the pulk Education
Association how bad has it gone it's
gotten bad this is day three of the
teacher year and I've already had two
teachers resign Kapos elo says teacher
pay is one of the biggest factors the
estimated national average teacher
salary last year was sixty thousand four
hundred and eighty three dollars in Polk
County it was just over forty one
thousand it's not competitive enough to
attract people not only do we have to
get them here but then we have to work
to retain them in their classrooms so
that we don't have this constant every
year churn Marianne was showing me the
teacher pay schedule in that an
entry-level teacher here in Polk County
makes about forty one thousand and if
they stay for ten years they only get
about a four thousand dollar raise not
much right but kale is Miss Lisa and
when you put it in perspective when she
started twenty three years ago she was
making twenty three thousand Wow you're
bringing a very ringing the bell David
about a very serious issue but your live
shot is very amusing you sitting in
Dominique's desk I like that miss Lee
this is serious TV I love first grade
thank you very much also you said ring
the bell bring it in bring in there
wasn't that you know school bell it's
really good yeah didn't we all look
first grade you get an outfit you get a
new Trapper Keeper
[Applause]
and so did they